[Music]
every friday during women's history
month we're taking a look at how the
coronavirus is affecting women and work
women in this country lost more than 5
million jobs over the past year
wow nearly 80 percent of those job
losses have been in government
retail education and health services and
leisure and hospitality services
they all have mostly female workforces
deborah flanagan worked as a travel
consultant helping companies coordinate
travel programs for their employees
and this is her story
i've been in the travel industry for 12
years i travel a lot so
it really was a good combination of the
things that i enjoy doing
when the pandemic hit debra flanagan
knew her
job was on the line by april the travel
industry was decimated
and she was laid off a call came in and
based on what i had seen going on in the
industry and i knew
kind of what the call was it was just a
little bit of shock but
it was it was mostly expected flanagan's
unemployment checks
and her husband's income kept the family
afloat
did you get all your homework done but
she had to make some changes
we just started cutting costs looked at
utilities and tried to
switch providers and do whatever we
could to
save a little bit i kind of immediately
got
you know my resume together there's
nothing under travel consulting it's
been really hard it comes up
empty quite a bit it's a really kind of
dead market right now deborah has now
turned her attention to building a
community newsletter
because she doesn't know if or when she
can ever return to the travel industry
going back into the industry it's going
to be a heck of a lot more competition
it's going to be a much harder climb
back
the unknown it's hard
it is so hard linkedin has been studying
this issue for its series it's called
conversations for change
carolyn fairchild is editor at large of
linkedin's global news team and joins us
this morning
carolyn it's really good to see you
there are a lot of deborah flanagan's
out there a lot of people are telling
the same story
so what do you think employers need to
do to keep women in the workforce
well good morning gail i'm glad that you
asked that question the pandemic has had
an outsized impact on the careers of
tens of millions of professionals what
we're finding is that women
particularly women of color are burying
the brunt of this crisis
there are 2.3 million deborah flanagan's
out there who are now
not in the workforce and what that means
is that women's participation rate in
the workforce
right now is at its lowest rate since
1988. so if employers don't act now
don't think about flexible workplace
policies don't check in with the current
women that they have in their workforce
we're risking decades of progress being
erased from women in terms of what
they've done in the workforce
since 1988. so carolyn i want to talk
about how we get women
back into the workforce so for people
who have lost their job during this
pandemic and how do they talk about that
job loss and that gap in their resume
when they go back out there on the
market
sure particularly for women career gaps
have been something that have been
stigmatized when it comes to returning
to work but the good thing about this
pandemic
is that that stigma has virtually gone
away we hear from hiring managers on
linkedin who say
they almost expect career gaps because
of the devastating impact this pandemic
has had on the labor force so
walk in confident knowing that that's
the case don't feel bad about it
actually come in with a case for
what you've done during this time the
skills that you've gained maybe you've
taken courses
that will help you with your next job
but really own the fact that this has
been a hard time for everyone and know
that you're not alone so carolyn there's
also
a difficult moment people face when
they're looking for a job particularly
looking for a long time and failing
at what point do people say i need to
change careers not just keep trying to
apply in the same area
we have data from linkedin right now
that's showing that women in particular
right now given just the devastating
impact that
the economy has had right now in
industries where we see a lot of women
you mentioned some of those industries
travel retail food and beverage these
are industries that have more women than
men in the workforce right now
and they're having to pivot and they're
thinking about different career paths
that they can go on and i think that
right now
the name of the game is skills how can
you transfer your resume from just a job
and an industry to the skills that you
have
so you can make that pivot into the
industries that are booming
you also say that it's all about
storytelling it's good to hear that
employers aren't judging you if there's
a career gap because when i was coming
it
up it was it was always said you don't
want to have a career gap
it doesn't look good a time out so you
say that it's about storytelling what
does that mean in getting a job
you have to sell yourself
it means that we have to rethink how
people think about their careers so many
people think okay it's my job title it's
the industry that i'm in
what we're seeing on linkedin in the new
digital economy is that it's about your
skills
transferable skills that you have let's
just take debra for example
the travel industry isn't a great place
to be working right now but her
experience
as a consultant that can be transferred
into e-commerce it can be transferred
into business sales
these are skills that she has that she
can then say and her resume painted out
as a story as you just said gail
in terms of getting her next opportunity
all right carolyn fairchild leading a
very
important conversation for us carolyn
thank you very much we hope it works out
for people who are listening